this is a major development in this case
as you say what has happened here over
the years that this hospital trust has
already been described as the worst
maternity scandal in the history of the
NHS and now the police are getting
involved they are seeing if it amounts
to what if what has happened here
amounts to criminal behavior we've had a
statement in the last few minutes from
the assistant Chief Constable of West
Mercia Police he says today we've met
with NHS improvement the Department of
Health and the independent reviewer to
discuss complaints made against
Shrewsbury and Telford NHS Hospital
Trust in relation to maternity services
and provision the independent review is
ongoing he says we can confirm that a
police investigation will be conducted
to explore whether there is evidence to
support a criminal case either against
the trust or any individuals involved
the investigation is now live he says so
we are unable to comment any further at
this time and he urges any family that
has not been in touch with the ongoing
independent review to get in touch with
police now we know that over a thousand
cases are being looked into we know that
this trust has already paid out millions
of pounds in damages to families who
suffered the avoidable loss of their
babies due to mistakes made in maternity
care we know that dozens of babies have
died unavoidably over the years here
some mothers - and we also know that
there are many babies who've been left
brain damage now what began as an
investigation led by an independent
midwife in 2017 into 23 possible cases
of clinical malpractice has now spiraled
to the point where as you say hundreds
over 1,600 families now in touch with
that independent inquiry now these are
families that have suffered here over
since 1979 but many of those I'm told
are much closer to the present day and
indeed I understand that the most recent
case being investigated is the death of
a baby this year the families
who have lost babies have long said that
this is a trust that has failed to learn
lessons and that is why mistakes are
repeated they have always said that the
needs to be accountability as I say
there is this ongoing independent review
into these cases that's not due to
report possibly until early next year
due to the huge number of families that
have come forward the huge number of
cases to look into but this police
investigation will now run in tandem
with that looking to see whether what
happened either as a result of the trust
or indeed individuals that have worked
here over the years whether there has
been criminal behavior as the police say
it is now a live investigation so they
won't be commenting any further we have
this evening contacted the trust for
their reaction to this major development
and we are awaiting their response to
this ok Becky thank you very much indeed